thank you mr speaker for granting this
urgent question and it is incredibly
disappointing but not unsurprising that
the prime minister of whom i asked this
question is not here today despite not
having any official engagements and i
think mr speaker his absence speaks
volumes as does he smirks on the media
the public have already drawn their own
conclusions he can run but he can't hide
mr speaker
i received an email this morning from a
man called john who told me on the 20th
of may 2020
i found
my longtime partner dead on the bathroom
floor i'd been unable to get a gp visit
for her and she had suffered terribly
for some time before the blood clot
stopped her heart
that day
[Music]
the house heard from the prime minister
himself that 181
nhs workers and 131
social care staff had died
many people
made huge personal sacrifices
and the minister quite frankly hides
behind the grey investigation there's no
need for an investigation into the
simple central question today did the
prime minister attend the event in the
downing street garden on the 20th of may
2020
it won't wash mr speaker to blame this
on a few junior civil servants the prime
minister sets the tone
exactly if the prime minister was there
surely he knew exactly the investigation
was sent the invitation was sent to a
hundred staff
many of them his own most
personal senior appointees this was
organized in advance mr speaker so did
the prime minister know about the event
beforehand and did he give his
permission for it to go ahead and if so
did he believe this event was that was
keeping with the restrictions at the
time and the guidelines and was the
chief medical officer consulted before
it went ahead
and what did the chancellor know about
the party given that he lives and worked
next door
and can the minister confirm that no
other ministers were present and finally
mr speaker
can i ask the minister here today
does he still believe the prime minister
to be a man of honor and integrity
[Applause]
mr speaker
her first point was that the prime
minister was not here in person she
knows as well as everyone else in this
house that it is not routine for the
prime minister to answer urgent
questions before this house but
his ministers his ministers are
appointed to do so but he also attends
this house more often than anyone else
to answer questions and we'll be doing
so tomorrow in the normal way at prime
minister's question time
uh
she mentioned the loss of um suffered
the appalling loss suffered by one of
her constituents and my heart goes out
to that constituent and indeed
to all of the others from whom we have
heard in this house on all sides of this
house who have suffered tragic loss as a
consequence of this appalling pandemic
there is a need for an investigation she
said there wasn't
there is a need and that need is clear
the investigation is in progress it's
being conducted by someone
with whom we have great confidence
and a if i can put it this way a paragon
of uh independence and integrity uh and
in the civil service of long-standing
she is conducting that investigation and
the prime minister uh was one was of
course himself affected by the
consequence of a covid19 uh infection uh
he takes this matter very seriously
as does everyone in government but i
will say this
she asks if i have confidence in the
prime minister's integrity and honor and
i do